and the mother of a toddler allegedly  killed by her boyfriend now arrested on  prostitution charges we are talking  about taylor nicholson who faced a judge  today  she is charged with three counts of  prostitution and one count of possession  of a deadly weapon  police say she offered sex to an  undercover detective and had brass  knuckles with her at the time  her boyfriend is charged with killing  her two-year-old son amari we'll update  you on developments regarding his  charges in just a moment  after taylor faced the charges today in  court the judge released her on her  own recognizance i would ask  any release be conditioned  her next court appearance is at the end  of july christian